my friend and former guest Vivek
ramaswamy has been making the rounds
talking about what's going on here with
Twitter and who is ultimately
responsible for what Twitter did
silencing dissenting voices
etc etc and here he is talking about how
it's possible that these people are
going to be charged with fraud he knew
they were doing something wrong and they
lied about it and still hid it they
absolutely were engaged in Shadow
Banning they had the public belief that
some of this was just done by AI when in
fact it was done by actual human beings
right and to me that's not just doing
something wrong when you lie about it it
means you are culpable because it means
you knew you were doing something wrong
and you did it anyway at the highest
levels and legally speaking to me that
forms a new basis for a legal claim of
Consumer Fraud which is actually telling
consumers you're doing one thing when in
fact you're doing another
okay so that's an important piece what
he said there at the end that were they
actually engaging in Consumer Fraud you
know one of the things I was saying
years ago I mean you can watch videos
from 2017 when a whole bunch of us
started talking about censorship online
first was that if these are pro are
public companies so Twitter is now a
private company because Elon bought it
but it was a public company and Facebook
is a public company and Google is a
public company they have a fiduciary
duty to their shareholders to do the
right thing financially by the company
if it had come out that actually they
were Shadow Banning these people thus it
was not the best inch it was not in the
best interest of the company that's not
what people thought that they were in
essence buying what the shareholders
were buying then there's a huge problem
the board is in direct conflict with
what its duty is to the shareholders and
Jack and the other Executives they
answer to the board so there's a Litany
of problems here but he's right it's not
just that they were doing this stuff by
Ai and pretending they didn't know what
was happening they're all on the record
saying it wasn't happening at the exact
same time sometimes on the record when
they were talking to Congress or the
Senate so there is there is a lot of
stuff here